Okay.
Sometimes it's easy to get a false sense of
security as someone who knows that we are
in the United States legally with an American
passport.
I was born in Argentina.
I came to the United States, my family had
the a visa lottery.
Uh, and when I was 17 years old, because my
parents were citizens, I was able to go to
the post office, fill out a passport application
form and that made me an American citizen.
So I have a level of comfort, uh, when I'm
talking to police officers or people from
border patrol, if I'm traveling down near
the southern border or whatever, um, that
is warranted in the sense that I know I'm
here legally, but at the same time it can
be a false sense of security.
We all the time hear horror stories about
migrants who are detained for days without
soap, without a toothbrush.
But we sometimes think it could never happen
to us because we are here legally.
And then we hear about and nine year old US
citizen with her passport who was detained
by border patrol for 32 hours in March.
We had one story last week like this, so if
an 18 year old American citizen, a Francisco
Erwin Galicia who was determined the detained
by a border patrol transferred to ice held
for three weeks, even though he had documents
on his person that proved he was born in Texas
within four hours of the Dallas morning news
reporting about it, Galicia was free.
The explanation, it was a so-called bureaucratic
mix-up.
Regardless whether detainees do or don't have
American citizenship, they shouldn't be held
without a shower for 23 days like Galicia
was.
It's UNAMERICAN and it's immoral and it is
the antithesis of what this country is supposed
to be, but it's even worse.
We've now learned of a nine year old girl
who in March was detained by border patrol
for 32 hours even though she was a US citizen.
I'm talking about Julia Medina.
She's American.
Her family lives in Mesut, Mexico.
They cross the border to go to school each
day.
She and her 14 year old brother were detained
by border patrol.
She had her passport on her, but border patrol
said the picture on the passport doesn't really
look like her.
She was questioned at nine years old without
her parents present.
When border patrol was asked, why did it take
32 hours to confirm her legal status as an
American citizen?
So far as of an hour ago, border patrol has
not had an explanation.
Border Patrol tried to have Julia's 14 year
old brother sign a document which said, actually
Juliette is his cousin, not his sister, insinuating
some kind of human trafficking angle to the
entire fiasco, which of course is untrue.
It was indeed his sister.
Border Patrol also said Julia provided inconsistent
information during her questioning.
She's nine years old, that she first say pizza's
her favorite food and later said that it's
hot dogs.
She's nine years old being questioned by law
enforcement without her parents.
Eventually Julia's mother was able to get
the help of the Mexican consulate who contacted
American immigration authorities.
So I'm not telling you this story to suggest
that this would be okay if Julia really wasn't
a citizen, right?
This is a moral crisis of the highest level,
no matter what the nationality of the kids
that are being detained is.
What I'm trying to point out to you is that
first of all, of course, this is hugely racially
tinge.
She's American with a passport, but she's
non White Hispanic, crossing the border from
Mexico.
Secondly, if you're angry about how she was
treated, realize that it's just as bad for
a nine year old without an American passport
to be treated this way.
It's really easy for us to sit back and not
react strongly when we're told, listen, a
lot of these kids in cages and kids being
detained and questioned by law enforcement,
with no lawyers or parents, a lot of them
are here illegally.
They're not American citizens.
These are children.
They're not deciding things for themselves.
If you're horrified by this story of the nine
year old US citizen, Julia Medina, you should
be just as horrified by the stories of non-citizen
kids as well.
Understand the gravity of the direction that
we are going here.
This isn't just becoming a papers please society
that we're developing.
It's one where even with the papers, it doesn't
help you.
Like it didn't help Julia Medina because apparently
as a nine year old, based on the combination
of her quote inconsistent answers and coming
over the border and not looking like the picture
on her passport, even then the papers were
not good enough to prevent a 32 hours attention
of a nine year old by immigration authorities.
I don't know what the solution is here it
is.
I mean, yes, it's obviously getting rid of
Donald Trump and changing the policy around
a lot of what is going on, but that's not
the solution in and of itself.
This is a much bigger problem.
Uh, make sure to follow the David Pakman show
on Instagram where we have a poll about this
issue at David Pakman show on Instagram.
And while
you're there, follow me